Speaker 1: ime. Look forward and look forward
to subscribing. One question I was surprised
that you would have agreed to be on Michael
Cohen's podcast. Can you clarify and talk a
little about why you chose to be on his podcast,
given his sketchy past to include tax and bank
fraud in addition to being disbarred by the
New York Supreme Court? Yikes. How does he
have any credibility left? Thank you. Yeah,
You know, I mean, listen. Appearing on a show
is not an endorsement of everything that person
has done. And if you go down this path, sort
of like, where do you draw the line? I mean, I'm
sure everybody who's interviewed me has lied. Some
of them have also cheated on their significant
others. That arguably could be a reason for me
to refuse to appear on some other shows. I mean,
this isn't how I think about things. You know,
you get invited to lots of shows and the
question is, is it worthwhile speaking to
the audience of that show? And the answer with
Michael Cohen's show was yes. So I appeared on
the show. It's really just that it doesn't
mean that I think it was okay when Michael
Cohen committed bank fraud or when some other
interviewer, you know, cheated on their spouse.
As many of the people that I've interviewed me,
if it's I'm not endorsing anything in particular.
I'm just doing the show. So I would just
say, don't think too much about that.
Yeah, maybe I'll just leave it there. Andrew wrote
in and said, Also, be fun to see you respond to
this on one of your videos, don't you, Will, as
it is one of your fake emails. At the beginning
I felt your channel had potential, but you went
extreme left and you now becoming a failure. No
wonder you need to endorse businesses that are
scam for money. You are desperate. You know what's
really funny? This is a really common. So I've
talked about unsubscribed trolls, right? Which are
now I'm unsubscribing and it's like you were
never subscribed. This one is. I used to have
positive feelings about your show, but because
of the things you did, I no longer do. I went
back and checked out the email. The reason we keep
all emails that are sent in sometimes because law
enforcement needs them. I know that that's
really sad, but unfortunately in this era.
When you've been doing this as long as we've been
doing it and your audience has a certain size, it
starts to become likely that some of your viewers
are going to be entangled with law enforcement.
And we keep all records in case we may at some
point need to turn them over to law enforcement.
But also just to see, for example, Andrew has been
writing in literally for years and every email
has been riddled with insults and pejoratives
and all sorts of stuff. He never thought that
channel had potential. He's been insulting me
since day one. And the other funny thing is,
now you're becoming a failure. The show is
bigger today than it has ever been before.
Might have been better earlier to
say your show will never be bigger
or something like that. But okay, that's
Andrew very, very important message.
Troll away wrote, wrote in and said Trump claims
he can't be anti-Semitic because he moved the
embassy to Jerusalem. So many Christians also
seem to claim to love Israel, but they hate Jews.
Many fundamentalist Christians believe it
is their duty to bring about Armageddon as a
step to bring about the rapture. Do you think the
president actually did it to placate these people
as Jerusalem? Becoming the capital is a step in
that goal? Excellent question. I've explained
so many times American Jews are very liberal,
one of the most left wing voting blocs in the
United States. And yet you often hear. But what
about Republicans as the supporters of Israel?
Republicans support Israel in a very narrow way
that is connected to the evangelical beliefs
about, as this email is pointing out, the rapture,
Armageddon, the second coming of Jesus, etc.,
etc. they don't like or it like isn't even the
right word. They are about the Jewish people as a
people, as a culture, as a community. They believe
their teachings in which Jews and Israel have a
particular role to play in Jesus Jesus coming
back and rapture and Armageddon and all of this
other crazy stuff. And yes, the Jerusalem thing
is part of that. I don't know that Trump had any
idea about that. Trump's view most likely was the
people on my side who talked to me about Israel.
Want the embassy in Jerusalem. So that's good. And
that's probably as far as Trump really is aware.
But a very good question and very accurately
pointed out there, Michael wrote in about
oversimplification of political issues, and this
is also a good topic as David started watching a
few months ago, really like the show. Have you
ever noticed how many right wing positions are
based on gross oversimplification of the issues?
Climate change. It still snows. Therefore, global
warming is a hoax. Gender. Just look between your
legs. Poverty. Just work harder. Immigration. Just
come in legally. Mental illness. Just snap out of
it. Systemic oppression. Pull yourself up by your
bootstraps. Abortion. It's always murder. STDs
just don't have sex. COVID vaccine. You still
get COVID, so it's useless homelessness. Go to a
shelter. Drug addiction. Just stop using and it
makes sense. You have to be that out of touch
with how things work for everyday people. To
be a right winger. Yet this is this is a big
academic topic. And Michael Michael may have
stumbled upon this on his own, but people like
George Lakoff and others have talked about how
the framing that the right uses for so many issues
is linguistically advantageous and it contributes
to this simplicity. We need tax relief. Taxes are
a burden. Lower taxes. People are relieved. That's
good, right? But you can't lower them to zero.
Then society ceases to function. Abortion. Well,
I'm pro-life. Everybody else must be against life.
Life is good. So being this is actually a really
big topic in the American political divide. And
Michael is completely right that the only way
that you would believe this stuff is if you really
are out of touch or lack information or, you know,
we've talked about the different categories,
but this is a this is a feature of Republican
politics, not a bug, because it makes it so
that completely untenable political positions
seem almost viable to some people by
virtue of their fabricated simplicity.
Michael wrote in about conservative checkmate
and says You should benefit from how you
are registered to vote. If you register as a
conservative, I guess Michael means a Republican.
You get to keep your total wage and pay no taxes,
but in return you get no services, no police,
no fire, no health care. You would have to pay out
of pocket for those services. If you register as
a Democrat, you pay 30 to 40% in taxes, but you
get health care, Social Security, fire, police,
etc.. Would conservatives be okay with this
idea? Now, I know that this I think anyway,
that this is a thought experiment from
Michael and it's one we've explored before
in practice. I don't know what the
average right wing winger would say.
Listen, you get to keep all your money, but you've
got to pay for every road that you use. I mean,
it sort of starts to become kind of like one of
these libertarian utopias which don't work at all.
I don't know what they would say, but obviously we
all know that this type of thinking is completely
impossible for any functioning society. But it'd
be a curious one to to ask them about for sure.
Anthony wrote in from Spain and says,
I'm a long time fan from Spain. Sorry
for my English. It's my fourth language. Little
subtle brag there. I wanted to ask you if you've
ever consider doing some Spanish language
videos. I want to recommend you to some of
my acquaintances who do not believe me when
I tell them about how bad U.S. politics are.
I also hear there's loads of disinformation in
Spanish, both here and in the U.S. and I don't
know of any Spanish speaking equivalent to your
show. I know it would probably have lower rely,
but you are one of the few that could reach that
public without sounding condescending since you're
a native Spanish speaker. So we've been looking to
do this for a while. I just don't have any time in
my day to produce content in Spanish in addition
to what I'm doing. But we are about to launch.
A dubbed version of our eclipse
to Spanish. So you'll see me.
The voice will be dubbed into Spanish. And I know.
I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. It's not
perfect. Is not perfect. I just don't have any
more time. Guys, it you know, we've got the live
streams and we've got the podcast and the YouTube
channel and the finance channel and, you know,
my my daughters needing diaper changes. I thought
I only needed like three diapers for the entire
first year. It turns out you need way more than
three diapers for that. It's crazy. I just can't
I can't do more content in Spanish. So we're going
to be doing a dubbing thing. I think it could do
quite well. And I'll tell you more about it when
it when it launches Land and Road in about Trump
and says past presidents have airports named after
them, perhaps a prison can be named after Trump,
of course, preferably with him locked inside.
Nice one landed I'm that's a presented without
comment. I won't even comment on that. And then
Duane wrote in about voter fraud and says, David,
I'm curious as to how many cases of voter fraud
that have been prosecuted from 2020 to the end of
22 have been Republicans compared to Democrats.
I keep seeing a case, it seems like every other
week, and it is not a Democrat. It's as if
any claim a Republican makes of a crime is
basically an admission of a crime they have done.
I may not be a smart man, but I know I'm seeing a
pattern here. Thank you, Dwayne. Yeah. So, you
know, part of this is does some voter fraud go
under the radar? But of the prosecuted
cases in the U.S. and there are very few
it is overwhelmingly Republicans and it's often
Republicans trying to prove a point. And then
the prove they point the point they prove is the
opposite. They want to prove how easy it is to get
away with it. Then they get caught. Sometimes some
Republicans were caught genuinely voting twice,
like for their some in some cases a dead relative.
We've seen these things anecdotally. Big picture,
there's very little voter fraud happening at
the micro level. For those who get prosecuted,
it is mostly Republicans.
Dwayne is absolutely correct.
Send in your thoughts, comments, questions
to info at David Pakman dot com. Sign up at
join pacman dot com to get all of our great
member benefits, including instant access to
the bonus show which you could go watch or
listen to right now if you were already in.